[Applause]
campaigners in charlottesville fought
for years to remove the statue of
confederate general and slave owner
robert e lee
on saturday morning their long battle
came to fruition
as peaceful crowds watched a
controversial figure of this nation's
troubled racial past removed
[Music]
the statue and another of general thomas
stonewall jackson
will be kept in a secure location both
say activists
symbols of a shameful past i think that
we're finally ready to be a community
that doesn't
telegraph through our public art that we
are
pretty fine with white supremacy four
years ago plans to remove lee's statue
became a flash point for white
nationalists
who descended on charlottesville in
scenes that shocked the world
[Applause]
in august 2017 32 year old heather heyer
was killed
when a neo-nazi rammed his car into a
crowd of anti-racism protesters
her killer was later sentenced to life
in prison
we the people are one step closer
to the tranquility promised by the
writers of the constitution
to form a more perfect union
we are so far from the perfect union
yet one step closer today as these two
statues
come down
in the years that followed memorials to
the pro-slavery confederacy were taken
down across the u.s
even more following the death of george
floyd at the hands of a white police
officer
to the young people out there i hope
that this empowers you
to speak up on the issues that matter
and to take charge in your own cities
and communities
no platform for white supremacy no
platform race for racism
and no platform for hate critics say the
statues are part of the heritage of the
us's southern states
others reminders of racial
discrimination and oppression that's
never gone away
according to the southern poverty law
center hundreds of symbols of the
confederacy remain in place
across the u.s even as the fight
continues to remove them
states like alabama mississippi and
tennessee are enacting policies
to protect them andy gallacher al
jazeera washington